shut up and sit down you big ball [ __ ]
give me that [ __ ] shrew
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that do
you know what nemesis means [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] a righteous infliction of
retribution back off manifested by an
appropriate agent Bonjour Isana fide in
this case by a horrible [ __ ] [ __ ] me
[ __ ] you I point these [ __ ] on ponies
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] it pikeys [ __ ] me
who the [ __ ] totally you boy Mary
[ __ ] Poppins are you taking the piss
bollocks kind of ass you [ __ ] idiots
bollocks the balls [ __ ] right past a
piece of [ __ ] so me a [ __ ] dog
and it's worth five [ __ ] but I ain't
[ __ ] buying that oh no a large six
governor but I'd already quite as
[ __ ] stupid as these two now [ __ ] off
you [ __ ] you took the [ __ ]
Jemma and more donuts on me I care if
he's got [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] eyes or nuts it's not as if he's
income [ __ ] spit your snare is its
get up have a [ __ ] fight now we are
[ __ ] goody gumdrops